penal animation
what's a top ten video with believe in
nation a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
because there's something more inside
you too you're a genius so here are my
dad's top 10 rule for success vol 11
let's kick it off with rule number 1
take on challenges everything in your
life will change when you realize that
you do not want an easy life stop
praying for easy stop praying for
convenience you don't want it because
you don't want to photocopy your life
every single day over and over and over
and over again you want to Riley
you want change you want something
different but with that variety comes
uncertainty comes pain comes challenges
and from that pain comes purpose
ultimately your purpose comes from your
pain and the more pain you go through
the more challenges you take on the more
you stretch yourself in your comfort
zone the more you're gonna be able to
reach down and help somebody come up to
your level as well you can only help
people to the extent you have been
through something so the next time
you're going through some pain you tell
yourself this is the best because it's
your chance to show yourself in the
world what you're made of
and we'll define the impact that you
will have most entrepreneurs don't
charge enough you're so worried about
getting rejected or losing clients
because of a higher price that you'll
charge just enough so you stay just
above their survival line that's not how
winning businesses are built if you
can't break your survival mentality
you'll stay in survival mode forever
so the first brand deal that I ever got
was for 500 dollars from a major
telecommunications company and they
wanted me to write for their website and
they hired me they hired nine of the
people to write an article and they said
write 300 words
we'll pay you 500 bucks and for me 500
bucks at the time I thought this is
great it's amazing out my first deal 500
boxes cash I'm pumped but more important
I'm getting a link from a huge company
in friendly buddy back in the old school
SEO days if you get linked from a big
company that can mean a lot for your
business to take off or rankings so I
would have done it for free just for the
link so they gave me the 500 bucks but I
didn't just write the 300 words because
I wanted to give more value I wanted to
get paid based off the value that I
could provide and so I had to show them
here's how much value I can bring and so
instead of writing 300 words I wrote
1500 words right five times more than
what they asked and then I made a video
talking about it and then I also
promoted to my newsletter list Pro to my
audience let people know when that
article came up here it was and so what
happened as a result of me doing all
this work I was the only one doing it so
when they came to the end of the series
I had my posts that were crushing it and
the nine other people were doing what
was asked to 300 words their bare
minimum what is asked of you is the bare
minimum that's your ticket into the door
if you just did what they asked that's
not enough now stop giving them insane
value and so I was the only one that
they hired ten of us went in I was the
only one who kept going because I
brought them way more value now I said I
charge you more what I was doing I went
for 500 bucks proposed to 1,000 to 1,500
to 2,000 kept increasing my prices
because I was bringing them the value
and they could see it rule number three
raise your standards one of the hardest
things in the world to do is to raise
your standards everything that you are
surrounded by keeps you where you are
your friends your family the media you
consume your habits everything your
environment has been perfectly created
to keep you exactly where you are right
now if you want to raise your standards
you need to raise your environment I met
up with a friend of mine recently who
I've known for 12-plus years and he was
talking about how much I changed over
the years and for those of you hardcore
fans of mine you can go back in my
content and see how much
but specifically for him he's an
entrepreneur I've seen his business grow
over the years and he talked about how
much more willing I was to be truthful
to be honest to push him to push him
when it was uncomfortable and believe in
him even harder to say the things that
are uncomfortable that need to be said
that will help me get to where he needs
to be to believe in people more than
they believe themselves he's seen the
changes in me and how much more direct I
am how much more confident I am and how
that's helped him directly in his
business and his life where did that
come from
it came from my videos if you go back
and watch my old content I didn't have a
lot of confidence I loved what I was
talking about I thought it could help
but I didn't have the emotional
commitment to the words a lot of my
messaging belief has stayed the same but
my confidence and my commitment and my
standards have raised because of the
videos that I consume because my
environment was a certain way and it was
pretty good but now in watching my own
channel watching my own content being a
subscriber to myself making my videos
for me and then sharing it with the
world I feel like I have all these
people on my wall and more in my ear
every day I've got Steve Jobs talking to
me every day I got Oprah Winfrey in this
ear I got Elon Musk back over here I've
got all these people every day all these
successful people in my ears constantly
when you are around successful people
you will become more successful when you
hang around these people you will start
to think like they think you will adopt
their mindset you will see the world the
way that they see the world and so you
have a choice look at your current
environment look at the people who are
currently hanging out with look at the
media that you are currently consuming
does it lift you up does it build you to
be a better version of you the thing
that you want to go off and do the
things you need most in your life are
you surrounding yourself with that
enough in your environment are you
taking enough of it in AI want more
belief in my life and so I get a daily
injection of belief through my channel
right I inject myself with belief every
day so that if you come around me and
you've got a cold and you sneeze on me
right you're a negative person you're
pessimistic you sneeze on me with your
negativity I'm good
because I have so much belief in me from
the injection rule number four focus on
your distractions you keep getting
distracted by might be the very thing
that you should be focusing on so many
people keep asking me hey man how do I
stop getting distracted how do I focus
on my work if you keep getting
distracted is for one of two reasons
either one you don't like the work that
you're doing or two you're afraid of it
working out the solution isn't to keep
avoiding it the solution is through and
chances are that's saying you keep
getting distracted by it's actually the
thing that you should be focusing on you
just don't know how to make it a
business yet now I'm a big believer in
the Suzy get an idea you test you try
you tinker you experiment idea that she
the two percent difference let's go
let's go let's go
so an example was my top 10 series when
I first started the top 10 series I
didn't think it would become a series I
didn't think it would become this huge
thing that could then later define my
channel and became the most popular
series on my youtube channel it started
up because a friend of mine mark posted
a blog about Kanye West and how he
interrupted Taylor Swift and this was
multiple years after he had actually
done that and like come on man
you can learn from Kanye dude stop
hating on Kanye yes he gets himself into
trouble he deserves it but he's also a
genius he's also someone that you could
learn from he's won more Grammy Awards
and anybody at his age he convinced John
Stephens to change his name to John
Legend because it had an old-school
voice it's all these amazing stories
about finding that you can learn from
his success and starting fine forget
this I'm not just going to complain I'm
going to take action and I'm gonna make
a top 10 rules for success from Kanye
West and I went out myself
I'm researched all these different clips
and then put them together and sure
there's a lot that you can't learn from
Konya there's a lot that you don't want
to model or copy and emulate into your
life in business I get it but there's
still 10 things at least you can apply
and learn from him to make you a better
version of you and so I just did it and
I released it and people liked it it was
meant to be a one-off video just to show
my friend mark to say just watch this
mark watch it learn
from it you can learn from Kanye and it
was a distraction project right I'm
working on my business I'm working on
trying to create something Marc creates
this blog post and I get distracted by
anything I want to make a video and I
can put my business on hold and socially
I'd known no forget that idea I need to
stop doing that I need to I need you to
just focus and forget all those
tractions no I said you know I'm gonna
put this on hold because I can't stop
thinking about this so I'm gonna do this
get it out of my system and then we're
gonna come back to my main business
although that little thing that I did
just as a one-off to show my friend Marc
ended up becoming the entire channel you
never know and so it's idea action
that thing that I got distracted by it
ended up becoming the beginning of an
entire series an iconic series on my
channel and it might be the thing for
you to also if you want more confidence
check out our to 54 series the link to
join us in the description below
surround yourself with greatness if you
want to be more confident you need to
surround yourself with things that make
you feel confident find whatever the
smallest first step is and in the
smallest next that is and continue to
build those steps I mean you look back
you'll have realized that you made it's
a pretty significant progress this is
why I think ten-year plans are almost
useless because if you are chasing down
your dreams then your goals will change
so many times over the next 10 years
think back to who you were 10 years ago
take today's date and imagine yourself
10 years ago could the person who you
were 10 years ago actually predict what
a great life would be for you right now
today 10 years later if you've had
growth over the past 10 years Dennis
know that it's a no way you've grown so
much of the person five years ago two
years ago let alone ten years ago has no
idea of what you're capable of this is a
danger of creating these ten-year goals
for yourself is you can get your
technicals you can have a goal and hit
it in ten years I just think that it's
small compared to what you could do
because it's looking back 10 years the
10 year younger version of you could not
actually predict what would make you
happy right now
then what makes you think that you right
now can create a great plan for you
looking forward 10 years you can't and
that's the best now I don't think goals
are useless I think goals are great I
think goals are stepping stone along the
path of your dream you have to just make
sure that your goals constantly align
with your dream nobody has the exact
life you want nobody this is why so many
people have a challenge learning from
mentors because you're looking for one
person to teach you everything that one
person does not exist because you want a
unique life because the perfect view
doesn't exist out there yet you have to
create it it's on you and so the way to
get through it is to model from
different people it's to look at I want
to learn this from this person and this
from that person this from this person
this from that person and mix all of
those things together to build an
amazing life for yourself this is partly
why I created my channel I want to be
able to model success from all sorts of
different people and every video that I
make I've learned something from all the
people that I throw around I have
learned something from them if I
personally meet you I've been Carmical
haven't learned something from that
video then I don't post it I think too
many people settle too early on in life
for the wrong aim people settle for the
wrong business people settle for the
wrong career people settle for the wrong
relationship because they're in such a
rush to get to their aim that they end
up with a life of suffering if you don't
know your aim yet that's okay it's
normal and maybe you found the velocity
that can happen to there may be many
times in your life where you don't know
your aim the solution is
taste is to test is to try is to explore
until you find it because otherwise you
live a life filled with regret knowing
that you are capable of more
but you settled for less breathing
should not be your priority learning
should be your priority there used to be
only a small number of ways to learn
they used to only be reading or maybe
going to lectures and learning from
people that reading was one of the
fastest ways to learn because you could
take somebody's life and in one book and
that's the whole thing all of the
lessons and here you go
chance to learn now though there's so
many different ways to learn there's
podcast there's videos and so you need
to understand what is the best way that
you learn reading does not have to be in
your top priority but learning has to be
the difference between where you are
today and where you will be in five
years
that growth will be in direct relation
to how much you learn how much you feed
this brain right here with knowledge
that shifts the way you think but it
doesn't have to come from reading so
looking at my store as an example I used
to read all the time growing up I used
to read I am 39 now so I used to read a
lot growing up it was the only way to
learn and the ideal be able to look at
any famous entrepreneur and look at
their story how they got started that
was a lot of knowledge that allows you
to step into somebody's world right if
you don't like your environment you
don't like the people around you you
don't want to become your parents or the
people in your community you want
something better you want something
bigger then you need to start to
surround yourself with those people and
reading is a great way to step into
their world and so I used to read every
single week not quite every day but
almost I was reading a lot I was
voracious but as soon as the video came
out I quickly shifted I would much
rather watch a video then read a book I
just learned better that way I would
much rather have an Elon Musk video
watch him and see him tell his story and
look at the body language that I would
read in a book about somebody else
telling Elon Musk's story that's me
that's how I learned I listened to zero
podcasts because auditory is the slowest
way for me to learn it was the only way
if the only way to
was to listen to podcast and I would be
all over it and I would force myself to
do it because I love learning but
because there's so many different
options and I love video first I default
to learning through video like this
videos like this on my multiple channels
and so video is by far number one for me
and I consume video pretty much every
single day of my life number two would
be reading and a huge drop down the
number two I'll read maybe three to four
books a year and then number three would
be auditory which would be podcast and I
consume zero podcasts I don't know that
I've listened to an entire podcast all
the way through it would have to be some
person that I can't find the video or a
book on and the only information the
only way to get it is to listen to a
podcast your story is the secret to
finding your purpose the thing that you
feel is holding you back and that you're
afraid of is actually the thing that you
need to lean into so that you can help
other people your purpose and life comes
from your pain and you can either
succumb to that pain and let it control
you for life or you can use that pain to
change the world so my biggest pain was
being an entrepreneur and struggling and
suffering and making $300 a month and
when the 30% of a company and turning
down extremely high paying jobs to go
often being entrepreneur and lived the
entrepreneurial life and I was too
embarrassed in a chain to tell my
friends that I was struggling and
suffering and not making any money and I
hated myself and I felt like a loser I
felt like I was adding no value I felt
like I was getting up every day and
working and working and working the
entire day and not seeing my friends and
not doing any other stuff that I wanted
to do because I was so focused on
building my business and I wasn't
getting results like nothing was
happening every single day and I was
tired of living way below the poverty
line and I told my business partner that
I quit and that was the worst day of my
life
that one day when I decided that I quit
eventually I woke up the next day and I
said I can't quit I'd rather no one
failed to not know and I asked myself
who else had done this before who else
had built a software company how can I
learn
from that person model their success to
build my own company up but I love
helping entrepreneurs now because I
struggled so much as an entrepreneur
that was my pain should you have a plan
B or not depends on your personality for
some people the only way they act is if
they are all in if they don't have a
plan B if they burn the boats but for
others the best way to get them to take
action is actually small starts to taste
to try to test if you want to quit
smoking do you go cold turkey and just
quit or can you use Nicorette and slowly
wean yourself off both strategies can
work but it depends on your personality
the same thing applies in business I had
a guy call into My Morning Show today on
Instagram and he's in a bind he is
making a lot of money he's making
$300,000 as a base salary pulling in
over a million with commissions at his
current job but he doesn't want to do
his job anymore he's tired of doing his
job he wants to have a bigger impact he
wants to make more money yes but he
wants to do something that's fulfilling
you know he wants to do something that
is coming from his soul and he's worried
that starting over starting from scratch
he's gonna lose all this money from this
high-paying salary and he's not gonna be
able to find success great
he's an all-in kind of guy the challenge
with all the kind of people is you can't
just do things on the side the smart
safe logical practical way to do it
would be keep your job and in the
evenings and on the weekends start your
business get it going when your side
hustle is making enough to support
yourself you can quit your job and go
all-in on that business but you have
something to fall back on you've got
your business it's growing right you're
making some money if you can support
yourself part-time from your business
then if you can go full-time you'll make
even more money that's what makes sense
it's practical its logical but if you
can't do it if you can't stay consistent
because you're an all-in kind of person
that plan won't work for you the way to
get through it is you have to go all-in
take a leave of absence go all-in
give yourself a year and recognize that
it's not fatal whatever job you're at if
this is your problem whatever job you're
at you have a
skill set what's the worst thing that's
gonna happen in the next year well maybe
you don't make it but maybe your
business is zero right you make zero
money from your business you have to go
back and get another job at least you
know it's better to fail and to know
than not to know you have a skill set
you can go back again another job maybe
you don't burn the bridge with your
company and you can get that same job
back if you want or maybe you move on
and get an even better job it's not
fatal you're not screwed for life and if
you don't do it you will always regret
it
and so he's wrapping up some of his
deals and then he's gonna take a leave
of absence and go all in his business to
find out to know because this
opportunity that he has in his head has
a limited time frame and if he doesn't
do it he's gonna regret it
and hate himself for the rest of his
life you become who you consistently
think about so if you compare yourself
to people who've done a lot more than
you competition who's who's way ahead of
you then you will rise up your standards
you will gain strength to go and match
them if you compare yourself to people
who haven't done as much people who are
down on the swamp people who are way
lower than you then you're gonna get
dragged down into the swamp as well I
don't think there's anything inherently
wrong with comparing yourself to other
people as long as you use it as a kick
forward to make yourself better
if you want to see my dad's top 50 rolls
for success go check out their video
right there next to me continue to
believe and we'll see you there the
people who win work the hardest because
they love what they do I hate spending
money till on making money if you do not
have money